[SPEAKER_01]: is one word, agency.
Agency is decision and is direction.
It is coordination.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is the ability to set priorities appropriately.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is strategic autonomy.
[SPEAKER_01]: And for African countries, it means negotiating from a place of strength, building trade systems,
[SPEAKER_01]: that show African markets and African interests turning data into decisions, and decisions into results and impact.
[SPEAKER_02]: In a more fragmented world, Africa cannot afford fragmented responses.
[SPEAKER_02]: Our greatest strength lies in acting together by investing in regional value chains, expanding inter-African trade, inversing innovation, and putting people at the center of economic transformation.
[SPEAKER_02]: because potential alone does not permit prosperity.
[SPEAKER_03]: Africa has enormous economic potential.
[SPEAKER_03]: Potential that can create millions of jobs, generate higher incomes, and expand opportunities for all.
[SPEAKER_03]: We know the tools that are needed to unlock this potential.
[SPEAKER_03]: We know the tools that work.
[SPEAKER_03]: The challenges to implement them, to finalize them, to ensure they work together rather than across purposes.
[SPEAKER_03]: That is what your discussions today will cover.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it is where the OECD is focusing our efforts in partnership with countries across Africa, enhancing tribe and investment opportunities, designing stronger education and skills policies, and mobilizing higher levels of financing for development.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the moment to strengthen Africa's voice, deepen regional trade, and build the resilience to navigate an increasingly complex global economy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good policy depends on good ideas, and good ideas emerge when people come together to solve shared challenges.
[SPEAKER_04]: We'll bring together leading economists in Africa and globally, including chief economists of international and African development finance institutions, economic advisors to the heads of states and governments across Africa, and high-level government officials, Africa's youth and the diaspora, and civil society.
[SPEAKER_04]: to brainstorm on Africa's solutions for Africa's development challenges in a multi-colour world.
[SPEAKER_02]: The decisions we take today will shape Africa's place in tomorrow's global economy.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is not simply about adapting to change.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is about meaning it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because Africa's future should be shaped by Africans.
[SPEAKER_05]: It is now an honor for me to invite Dr. C.D.
[SPEAKER_05]: Utzah, President of the African Development Bank Group, to deliver his welcoming remarks.
[SPEAKER_05]: Please give him a warm round of applause.
[SPEAKER_00]: Minister of Development for the Government Group of the Bank of Africa and Development.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is my sister, Assistant Secretary-General of the United Nations Development Programme.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is Maria Petila Polido Gonzales.
[SPEAKER_00]: Director for Development, Corporation and OECD.
[SPEAKER_00]: Participants online, distinguished chief economists, development partners, leaders, students, ladies and gentlemen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good morning.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is my great honor to welcome you to the 2026 African Economic Conference, the 2026 annual meeting of the Global Chief Economist Network and the inaugural meeting of the African Chief Economist Network, the ACEA Network.
[SPEAKER_00]: The theme of this year's edition of the African Economic Conference
[SPEAKER_00]: strengthening Africa's geopolitical agency and is really timely.
[SPEAKER_00]: The African Development Park Group launched the African Economic Conference in 2006 as a platform for political exchange, policy dialogue, and collaboration on African issues and priorities between the policy and community.
[SPEAKER_00]: The AEC 2026 is by the bank in collaboration with the United Nations Development Program, NDP, Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: This year's AEC is the annual meeting of the global networks of chief economists, of international development agencies, and finance institutions, who will be in partnership
[SPEAKER_00]: with the Organization for Economic Cooperation and Development, OECD, which serves as the head of secretariat.
[SPEAKER_00]: This forum brings together chief economists from leading bilateral and multilateral development institutions to exchange perspectives on emerging global economic challenges, development finance, research, data, and efficiency-based policies.
[SPEAKER_00]: In addition,
[SPEAKER_00]: The African Development Fund will launch the African Chief Economist Network, ACE Network, in collaboration with the OMBP.
[SPEAKER_00]: The ACE Network brings together several African economic policy leaders, including chief economists of African multilateral and development finance institutions, regional and international organizations, central banks, national treasury, regional economic communities,
[SPEAKER_00]: leading think tanks and universities as well as eminent African economists and former senior economic policy makers to harmonize policy diagnostics and advisor service to African countries.
[SPEAKER_00]: The African Development Bank will also host a graduation ceremony for the second cohort of the Public Finance Management Academy for Africa and the first cohort of the Macro-Economic Policy Management Academy for Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: insuring 435 officials from over 36 countries across the continent to be certified as experts in public finance, management, and macroeconomic policy management practice, respectively.
[SPEAKER_00]: These events are proven at a pivotal moment in the world's history.
[SPEAKER_00]: The global order is being fundamentally reshaped.
[SPEAKER_00]: Trade patterns are shifting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Supply chains
[SPEAKER_00]: are being reorganized.
[SPEAKER_00]: Technological competition is accelerating.
[SPEAKER_00]: Financial flows are becoming more fragmented and geopolitical tensions are increasingly influencing economic patterns.
[SPEAKER_00]: The world is no longer organized around a serious center of gravity.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have really entered a mid-temporal era.
[SPEAKER_00]: These shifts present opportunities for Africa to strengthen its own agency in the global market, and to actively shape its role in the emerging reforms in the global economy.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is why the theme of this year's conference, strengthening Africa's geopolitical agency and trade resilience in the multicultural world, is so kindly relevant.
[SPEAKER_00]: For decades, conversation about Africa's place in the world
[SPEAKER_00]: have often focused on dependency, vulnerability, and adaptation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Today, we must focus on agency, resilience, competitiveness, and influence.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa has moved from being affected by global developments to helping to shape them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa's geopolitical agency will be measured by several factors, prominent among which
[SPEAKER_00]: which is its ability to renegotiate from a position of strength, shape the rules of engagement, translate its collective intellect into collective action, and intimately influence outcomes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Excellencies, ladies and gentlemen, this vision aligns closely with the strategic direction that I have activated for the African development group,
[SPEAKER_00]: through the four cardinal points and the new African financial architecture for development must pass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa needs to mobilize capital and state.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that requires that it can strengthen its political, its geopolitical position and create resilience.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa also must strengthen its financial architecture
[SPEAKER_00]: in an era of growing fragmentation that requires deepening coordination, amplifying the voice of the continent in global economic governance.
[SPEAKER_00]: Moreover, the future of geopolitical events will belong to nations and regions that can transform human production into productivity, innovation, entrepreneurship, and leadership.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa must be clear of resilient infrastructure, strengthen logistics, develop regional value chain, and create industries that create greater value as a country.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you, Professor.
[SPEAKER_00]: The full Cardinal Point provides a practical roadmap for strengthening Africa's geopolitical agency as economy prevails in a rapidly evolving global landscape.
[SPEAKER_00]: In addition, the new African Finance Architecture for Development, NAFAR, will facilitate effective coordination, complementarity, subsidiarity, and discipline risk transformation to allow Africa to mobilize, leverage, and deploy a capital at the scale required to drive structural transformation in the country.
[SPEAKER_00]: Over the coming two days,
[SPEAKER_00]: I encourage all participants to challenge conventional thinking, explore innovative ideas, forge new partnerships, and focus on practical solutions.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let us use this event to help shape the knowledge base for the African world.
[SPEAKER_00]: A structurally transformed and resilient Africa that develops on its own terms, based on its own knowledge systems and research evidence,
[SPEAKER_00]: and leverages smart partnership within the continent and across the world to accelerate inclusive and sustainable development in Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me commend Professor Kevin Oramah, the Bank's Chief Economist and Vice President for Economic Governance and Knowledge Management, and his team for their full service.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like also to thank both UNDP and OECD
[SPEAKER_00]: for their continued collaboration and for all of the institutions to stand together to advance Africa's knowledge.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thank all our partners who are participating today, particularly the United Nations Economic Commission for Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wish you productive and inspiring deliberations, and I look forward to the transformative ideas and partnerships that will emerge from your deliberations.
[SPEAKER_00]: On that note, it is my distinct honor to welcome you to the African Development Bank Group and to the 2026, to the African Economic Conference and to the 2026 edition of the Chief of Economists' Annual Meeting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you for your attention and wish you all success in your job.